à Kiev attaque sans précédent nous
dit-on par leur puissance leur intensité
et leur variété
oui tout à fait c'est ce qu'on confirme
ce matin les autorités ukrainiennes
alors pourquoi sans précédent a bien
parce que c'est une attaque extrêmement
intense qui vient qui vient jeter sur le
crâne 30 missiles alors les autorités le
commandant des forces armées d'ailleurs
Valéry zalujni a confirmé que 29 des 30
missiles lancés ce matin contre
l'Ukraine par la Russie avait été
intercepté alors à première vue c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait dire il y a quand
même c'est quand même assez positif d'en
avoir 29 d'intercepté sauf que les
forces ukraines les forces russes
justement comptent sur la saturation des
systèmes de défense entière
Ukrainiens pour avoir un métier qui va
tomber là où il cible quelque chose
alors ici à Kiev on n'a pas déploré de
blessés ce matin il y a eu un édifice
non résidentiel il s'agit d'un complexe
automobile qui a été visée qui a pris
feu suite à la chute de débris de ces
missiles intercepter par la défense
entière de Kiev en revanche vous l'avez
mentionné une personne est morte ce
matin à Odessa deux autres ont été
blessés lorsque lors de la chute de d'un
missile sur un complexe industriel il y
a également eu il y a également eu des
frappes dans l'ouest du pays dans la
ville de Vinicia et de Roumanie